I get when Ben Shapiro comes out and he
says here is my argument for war like
not for war but like why war is
happening we didn't he's like he's like
Israel didn't start it I don't know if
he says we but uh Israel didn't start it
Hamas starts it this current round I
know there's generational conflict here
but I get it Ben Cho says Israel is
Justified in doing these things for
these reasons and I'm like oh that's
really interesting why is the US
involved in this right why why why who
in this country I mean benir obviously
thinks the US needs to be involved to
prevent destabilization of the region
eventually World War III I I get his
arguments I would argue the inverse I
don't know which one is more likely to
happen but the US sending troops into
Gaza sounds like you're going to get I
don't know who the rebels in Yemen and
Iranian backed militias directly
attacking isra Israeli like territory I
mean the US going in maybe there the the
hope is that it will be such a massive
shock to the rest of these these
countries it will stop them from doing
anything